[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango in the movie guide and I am
so excited because this Thursday the
Sundance Film Festival starts and this
is my mecca it is all independent films
and I love it
I'll be keeping you guys in the loop
with everything that I see and all my
favorites from Sundance and I'm going to
try to see as many films as humanly
possible while at the festival but right
now I thought I would give you my 10
most anticipated movies coming up at
this year's Sundance Film Festival this
list is in no particular order but let's
start with one of the opening night
films I don't feel at home in this world
anymore this is directed by maken Blair
it's his directorial debut and you might
recognize me kin if you're a fan of
Jeremy sanyas movies if you've seen blue
ruin and green room he is the actor from
those movies and I can't wait to see
what he cooks up behind the lens the
story is about a depressed woman who
stumbles into the underground alongside
her neighbor after trying to track down
the people who robbed her it stars
melanie lynskey and elijah wood it was
all shot in portland and netflix has
already picked up the deal for this one
Ingrid goes west is another directorial
debut this time from writer Matt Spicer
and the synopsis sounds great it's about
a girl who is obsessed with an la-based
Instagram lifestyle influencer and other
fantastic female actor Jenny slate will
be in landline directed by Gillian
Robespierre and these two work together
on obvious child this one is set in 1995
New York and it's all about family
relationships continuing my theme of
great young female actors on your Taylor
joy from the which an Olivia Cooke from
me and Earl and the dying girl will be
starring together in a film called
thoroughbred which is all about these
privileged girls rekindling their
childhood friendship and
also stars the late Anton Yelchin I'm
still really sad that he's gone but I'm
glad that we have some of his movies
left to still watch a film that was
announced really late in the lineup
because it's only just being finished is
one that I cannot wait to see it's
called newness and it stars nicholas
hoult and it's all about young people in
LA navigating hookup culture and online
dating and social media and the main
reason that I'm excited to see this one
is that it's directed by Drake Deramus
this will be his fourth time at Sundance
first he was there for douchebag and
then like crazy which I love another
Anton Yelchin film then breathe in
and now newness speaking of Directors I
am keen to see Wind River because this
is the directorial debut see a theme
this is why I love Sun nets of Taylor
Sheridan now Taylor is a writer he was
behind the screenplays of a Sicario and
hell or high water and many many others
so I can't wait to see what he does the
plot sounds great it's about an FBI
agent who teams up with a game tracker
to solve a murder on a Native American
reservation and stars Jeremy Renner and
Elizabeth Olsen
so yes start your comments now about
Hawkeye and Scarlet Witch but these two
are great indie actors as well in terms
of writing debuts I can't wait to see
the big sick which has been written by
Kemal Nanjiani from Silicon Valley and
Emily Gordon and this is actually all
about their relationship and how his
parents sort of disapproved of him
dating Emily Kemal stars in the lead
role and then the role of Emily is
played by the wonderful Zoe Kazan it's
been directed by Michael Showalter who
recently did hello my name is Doris so
it's ticking all the boxes on the horror
side of things yes I'm a loss but I
always try to go to the midnight
screenings because they are a lot of fun
even though I'm terrified there's a
couple of Horrors that I'm really
looking forward to the first one xx is
an anthology of four short horror films
all directed by women then there's 7852
which is a shot-for-shot and
action of Hitchcock's famous shower
scene from psycho and Berlin Syndrome is
directed by Ozzy Cates Shortland and it
stars the wonderful Teresa Palmer and
she plays an Aussie backpacker who has a
fling with a guy in Berlin and then he
holds her captive those are ten of the
movies that jumped out to me straight
away but there are so many more like the
Inconvenient sequel which is the
follow-up to Al Gore's climate change
documentary or manifesto which sees Kate
Blanchet playing 13 different roles
delivering manifesto is about art and of
course I'll be taking you along for the
journey
next week's fandango indie movie guide
will be coming to you from Park City
Utah I'll be able to tell you about all
the films that I've seen so far you can
also follow me on twitter at Alicia
Malone I'll be doing daily vlogs on my
YouTube which is movies are my jam
plenty of ways to follow me around at
Sundance I like to take you along to
make you feel like you're part of the
experience as well because I know I'm
lucky that I get to go and I'm come out
for eight I'm Alicia Malone and I will
see you next week bye